the Joe Rogan experience you know like I
was there I saw everything I cut it up I
do yeah
I didn't butcher it myself but we
quartered it it means you take the legs
off and the back straps off and you take
all the big parts of meat and then I
send it to a butcher and they'll make
sausages and cut it into yeah how do you
get the elk back to California cooler
just like freeze it I'm not playing
yep yeah Yeti Yeti coolers they have
these things called a Yeti hopper so
it's like a bag like a big bag like
about this big and you can get two back
straps in there from an elk elk back
straps like you know elk so bigger yeah
you don't know animal I just love the
idea that there's all these people on
planes with like yeah they're going to
LA with a little dog and there's just
like elk meat in storage overhead you
put in the overhead yeah yeah wait for
real for real
you have elk meat a hundred percent but
that's great that's hot yeah well you
have to do it if you I can either send
all of it to the police or security are
they like what's going on do you know
you got an elk yeah I mean they know
only places like Utah they're used to
that this makes me so mad because I had
an Alexander McQueen purse you know and
you guys know Alexander McQueen purses
right you're familiar with the line they
have ones that have like rings that you
like you put your hand through and it's
like a bunch of rings attached to the
purse well I brought it through security
and they were like no you have to check
this because it looks like brass brass
knuckles oh come on
and so I had to check my McQueen purse
my little quilted patent leather McQueen
purse that's so ridiculous and you
couldn't bring elk
well Tony hench could have tried to
bring a pool stick we went to this is
what's this here's what's really crazy
we went to Phoenix this past weekend
we're working together and my friend
Scott Frost has a shout out to Scott
Frost has a place in Tempe this big pool
hall Scott's like a big-time gambler
pool player a professional pool player
very famous guy in the world of pool and
so we were gonna go and play at his
place and so Tony brought his pool cue
and in LA
didn't even check it he just walked
right through security with a pool cue
pool kills totally illegal to bring on a
plane so we're walking around LAX and I
go hey man you have a [ __ ] pool cue
with you he goes yeah I go how did you
do that it was I just walked right
through what because yeah I just walked
right dude that's illegal you can't have
that he was I'm pretty sure it's legal
now so on the way back from Phoenix they
were like what the [ __ ] you doing he's
like I'm just gonna bring the pool cue
on the plane it was like no you not go
check that [ __ ] so he had to go back out
we had to hold on to his bags he went
back out he had to go back to the
counter and check it and come back wait
why is it so illegal cuz you should put
someone to death with it all right I was
thinking poke you somehow get into the
cockpit you're just like fly to Miami no
it's a hardwood club basically oh that's
yeah I'm dumb that's a better that would
be a better way to lose a weapon how
many wants a Steven Seagal movie alright
but there's so much stuff like that like
oh yeah well they sell glass bottles
yeah inside the terminal which you could
break oh yeah yeah and then have a glass
weapon right but but don't they hold
those wouldn't you have duty-free don't
they whole long that stuff and then you
get it later and buy glass bottles of
like like sparkling water in like in
throughout the thing I think you can
yeah you definitely can buy a bottle of
water like a water bottle but can you
buy like a Voss bottle I think so I've
never seen one I think they have the
little glass sparkling ones I might be
we're not both before [ __ ] here yeah
write it out I brought a big big [ __ ]
knife once on a plane really went right
through security at LAX again with a big
know my friend Jocko gave me this night
shoutout to Jocko and gave me this knife
and I had it in my fanny pack and I just
went right through security yeah it's a
[ __ ] click a big hefty knife yeah and
I was like wha
I got got back to my place and you know
it's like I was in my hotel room that I
noticed I had I was like holy [ __ ] well
look I'm just getting cited when I can
get hair product through what's the rule
on hair products well it's supposed to
be under whatever 3 ounces but
everyone's and I'll forget or like I'll
be like running late and I'll throw in
like the full-size bottle and luckily a
lot of times it'll be like black women
though I'll be like they'll see in the
video if it's fine go ahead okay thank
you so much oh my god no [ __ ]
terrorists it's so ridiculous and also
it's hard to find you know the right
hair product they were gonna let people
bring knives again they were gonna let
people bring 4-inch knives and they were
gonna let people bring pool cues but
then I think something happened and
there was another event oh you know what
it was you remember at LAX where that
guy shot one of the TSA agents like who
came to LAX a rifle and shot a TSA agent
that's right when that was going down
then they locked it down so if I was a
conspiracy theorist I'd say they don't
want us bringing little knives and pool
cues so they shot that guy the false
flag I mean it it's logical though I can
follow the logic it's just the what they
can't what you can and can't bring is
crazy like how come you could bring a
skateboard I could beat someone to death
of a skateboard oh yeah I'm waiting
better than a pool cue
yeah also it's like you couldn't just
have a bunch of 3-ounce things that you
combine together yeah make a big bomb
yeah yeah yeah you have a bunch of
3-ounce things in an empty tub yes empty
tub for nothing why is it have a fuse
you don't know this is poison yeah right
it could be anything
Yeah right like those little - you could
definitely take something and I probably
shouldn't even say this yeah I don't
wanna give anybody any ideas because if
I what if I did say that and then
someone did do that see there's a lot of
people that are really crazy and not
that creative right no no yeah yeah they
like there's just like I've only there a
new way to do this like use your brain
but like the shoe bomber that [ __ ]
[ __ ] now everybody has to take their
shoes off yeah
nobody took their shoes off before he
had a bad
Shuba it's terrible yeah but he was
trying to light it in front of everybody
didn't even do in the bathroom the
[ __ ] idiot is that what you do you
light bombs if I was gonna light a bomb
I'd let it in the bathroom
yeah I would slide it flush it and then
no and then stop and like like you don't
even know what's happening like action
movies where the bomb goes off behind
you yeah yeah do you just walk let's
walk down the aisle you're just hoping
someone instagrams it at the right time
do you like oh we're all gonna die but
also what a good post but also hopefully
your phone is really durable yeah we did
get this amazing action [ __ ] them yeah
it's a it's a weird thing that that
everybody gets super super checked
flying but you don't get super super
check when you go to the mall you don't
get super super checked there's all
these other places where you don't get
super super checked yeah I mean I feel
like there should just be metal
detectors everywhere how hard is it to
get on the train very easy yeah
[Applause]